this video was made possible by
curiositystream watch an exclusive
behind the scenes video finally
answering the question of how we make
these videos by signing up for the
curiosity stream nebula bundle deal at
curiositystream.com
wendover
in the early morning hours of august
22nd 2021 the maersk essec pulled away
from birth 402 at the ports of los
angeles california after navigating
through the breakwater the ship made a
westward turn beginning a two-month
seventeen thousand mile twenty seven
thousand kilometer voyage from america
to asia and back
this is in the context of today's ocean
shipping industry a rather unremarkable
journey on a rather unremarkable ship
just 15 years ago though the maersk
essex would have been truly
extraordinary you see the essex boasts a
capacity for 13 092 20-foot containers
or teu 20-foot equivalent units in 2006
the zen los angeles entered service with
the capacity for 9600
teu
this was heralded with proclamations of
a new era for shipping as the gen ranked
as the single largest container ship
sailing the oceans in summer 2021 though
the ever ace took its maiden journey
from asia to western europe with a
capacity for 23
tu two and a half times more than the
largest ship of a decade and a half ago
as a point of comparison that means this
one ship could carry every single
container the 100 000 person nation of
saint vincent and the grenadines
received in 2020 at once and then add
bermuda's annual container traffic on
top of that now this trend towards
larger and larger ships is indicative of
another major trend in the shipping
industry consolidation
recognizing the incredible economies of
scale in an industry founded on the
principles of economies of scale the
largest container shipping lines
recently worked to reap a cost advantage
that their smaller competitors could not
by aggregating a larger quantity of
containers onto fewer ships this is both
a cause and effect of the fact that in
2000 the top 10 shipping lines
controlled 51 percent of the global
market but now they hold 85 percent
bolstered by historically low ship
building costs maersk msc evergreen and
others elected to order these new
behemoth ships rather than buy or
renovate used ships to operate on their
busy asia to europe and asia to western
north america routes so a 13 000 tu
behemoth like the essex a record breaker
in the wrong year is now but a rather
unremarkable workhorse of a ship fixed
on a regular route from los angeles
after an uneventful 10 days traversing
the pacific the maersk essex stopped at
its first port of call yokohama japan
the stop lasted 8 hours as cranes
unloaded containers from the americas
then loaded more bound both east and
westward soon enough though the essex
pulled in its lines thrusted away from
the dock and carefully navigated its way
out of tokyo bay once it reached open
water however it actually slowed down
slightly for rather strategic reasons
you see in 2008 in the early days of the
financial crisis shipping lines faced a
perfect storm of circumstance shipping
demand was rock bottom and fuel costs
were sky high the lines had to innovate
to survive and so a working group at
maersk came up with a stunningly simple
proposition
just go slower you see like most
vehicles ships are more efficient at
slower speeds but companies were always
worried that operating a ship over a
long distance below its designed
cruising speed could damage its engine a
quick way to squander any fuel savings
maersk proved this belief false though
and so began operating many ships at 14
to 18 knots rather than 22. this proved
financially advantageous most industry
players observed 10 to 25 fuel savings
on a given journey and in time going
slower became standard practice
industry-wide of course when the
shipping market's hot lines will operate
at higher speeds since they'd rather get
cargo to its destination and pick up
more containers sooner but when it's not
it's a simple way to simultaneously
reduce operating costs and remove
capacity from the system when it's not
needed this is exactly what the maersk
essec did after leaving yokohama with no
need to get to its next destination
quickly it reduced speed all the way
down to 12 knots as it meandered through
the east china sea which doesn't seem
like it'd be a notable practice but slow
steaming has been one of the most
significant industry innovations of the
21st century given the slow pace it took
five days for the essex to arrive at the
port of shaman china where it sat for
some 36 hours as thousands of containers
were unloaded in the afternoon of
september 8th though it pushed off once
again ready to venture deeper into the
far east on this stretch of the journey
through the south china sea the vessel
passed closest to the country that most
of its crew members call home the
philippines you see with few labor laws
regulating who can work on ships sailing
in international waters it's only
natural that cost-conscious shipping
lines look for staff from the lowest
cost of living countries in short they
look for those that they can pay least
arising from a mix of culture tradition
and education the philippines has
established itself as the single largest
source of maritime labor in the world
some 77 of ratings unlicensed low-paid
junior mariners that assist with some of
the most physically demanding tasks are
from the philippines
overall the industry unperturbed by
national boundaries is incredibly
international a danish-owned ship will
be built in south korea registered in
panama captained by an american and
crewed by mariners from the philippines
india bulgaria russia and beyond
the westernmost point of the maersk
essex journey was here the port of
vangtai vietnam it tied up to its dock
on september 10th these brief port
visits offer most crew members some rare
moments of continuous free time as the
cranes handle the work of loading and
unloading the ship the crew is typically
allowed to leave the ship see the sights
experience some nightlife so long as
they're back on board in time however
because of the border restrictions
imposed by many countries in response to
the covet 19 pandemic this practice of
brief short visits to foreign countries
has become impractical or impossible
further toughening an already difficult
style of life so after it's 44 hours
physically but not practically in
vietnam the essex started spinning its
propeller once again on september 12th
and the crew members went back to an
endless routine on an endless ocean
now some of vietnam's primary exports
include shoes clothing and textiles
these are typically not very price dense
products for example a box of cheap
shoes takes up a good amount of space
but might only sell for twenty dollars
in the us however the fact that a
company can manufacture shoes in vietnam
ship them across the world to the us and
still turn a profit on a 20 sale price
is indicative of just how unbelievably
inexpensive ocean shipping is on a human
level before the tumult that kovid
brought to the industry shipping lines
typically charged about one thousand
dollars to carry a 20-foot container
from asia to the us
that 20-foot container could hold some 3
500 shoeboxes meaning the cost to
transport a shoebox 8 000 miles or 13
000 kilometers across the world from a
port in vietnam to one in california was
about 30 cents
when people talk about ocean shipping
enabling globalization
this is what they mean the fact that
transporting a shoebox quite literally
to the other side of the world costs
less than a single mcdonald's chicken
nugget means that location and distance
are hardly factors in today's world of
manufacturing
the maersk essex's next stop was hong
kong were adopted at the quite sim
container terminal for 32 hours between
september 15th and 16th it then took a
slow meandering path around the
territory dropped anchor for 24 hours
then worked its way into the port of
yanchan located near the factories of
shenzhen
now with its capacity for 13 092
containers there are of course 13 092
different spots where a container could
go on the maersk essex
naturally in practice it's far from
random
complex expensive computer programs
crunch a huge variety of factors to spin
out the ideal storage plan for a given
journey to start with there's the
obvious stuff you want in this journey's
case the containers for yokohama to be
placed on top of those for shaman so one
doesn't have to unload shaman containers
to get to the yokohama ones when there
then the program needs to be sure that
certain containers are in particular
positions refrigerated containers need
to be in a spot with a power supply
while those carrying goods with the
potential for leakage like animal hides
need to be placed in a spot where they
can be easily accessed by the crew while
underway meanwhile other containers must
not be in particular spots this table
displays the regulations for the storage
of hazardous materials it indicates that
items that are dangerous when wet for
example must be stored at least six
meters away from radioactive substances
while corrosive materials must be stored
in a completely different compartment of
the ship from infectious substances on
top of these and a multitude of
additional factors the ship has to be
roughly balanced meaning overall the
storage plan is a massive game of 40
tetris that only a computer can perfect
after 52 hours of implementing that plan
the essex made a quick overnight journey
up the coast to arrive back in shaman
where it made its longest stop yet 56
hours loading a final batch of
containers
this was also the last chance for the
ship to load up on food and fuel before
what would be by far the longest leg of
its journey finally just before 6 am on
september 24th loading was complete and
it was time to shuttle another payload
of thousands of containers to north
america the maersk essex passed taiwan
worked its way through the east china
sea then threaded the gap between south
korea and japan after hugging the
country's coast it sailed through the
busy bottleneck of the tsugaru strait
and entered the cool open waters of the
northern pacific the essex entered
american waters for the first time as it
sailed near the alaskan aleutian islands
but then exited the country's exclusive
economic zone as its track started to
trend south after nearly two weeks on
the move the ship's path started to
parallel the california coast until the
essex passed the state's channel islands
and turned east on october 6 it slowed
to a stop dropped anchor and then just
sat
on october 7th it did the same
nothing more happened on october 8th 9th
10th in fact for the next 17 days a
longer stretch than his trans-pacific
journey the maersk essex sat on anchor
within sight of california's largest
city
waiting for an open birth
the time finally came on october 23rd
after 62 days the maersk essex arrived
right back where it started
birth 402 at the port of los angeles
now the port of los angeles is located
right next to the port of long beach and
while the facilities are technically
independent from each other they take
advantage of shared infrastructure like
roads and railways
combined the complex handles about 40 of
all container cargo coming into the
country this is because like most of the
industry ports benefit hugely from
economies of scale you see for imports
coming from asia it rarely makes sense
to send ships to the east coast despite
that being the side of the country where
the majority of the population lives
that's because that would require
routing through the panama canal whose
largest set of locks can only
accommodate ships up to 14 000 teu
smaller than many new container ships
and even then transit fees are well into
the hundreds of thousands getting a slot
can be difficult and routing via the
canal extends journey times
significantly that's why most asian
imports are offloaded on the west coast
but the us really only has five major
deepwater container ports on the pacific
long beach los angeles oakland tacoma
and seattle located in by far the
largest metro area on the coast the
ports of long beach and los angeles have
naturally evolved into the busiest as
they have the greatest access to labor
transport and infrastructure these three
factors are the most important for ports
because after all nobody's shipping
things to the port of los angeles
they're shipping things through the port
of los angeles it's all about getting
cargo containers from the ship and on to
onward transportation as quickly and
efficiently as possible
now the port itself is essentially the
landlord to a number of private
companies that actually run each
container terminal for example this
facility is run by using terminals this
one by everport terminal services this
one by phoenix marine services and this
one where the maersk essex started and
finished its journey by apm terminals
now once the essex was docked the first
step was to physically remove containers
from the ship which was accomplished
with these massive cranes each typically
unloads 30 to 40 containers per hour
onto trucks that move the containers to
a temporary storage location somewhere
in the terminal then there are three
possible onward transportation methods
first they could be loaded on a smaller
ship or barge that moves the containers
to a smaller nearby port although this
is rare in los angeles compared to a
place like the pearl river delta where
there are plenty more water access
population centers and industrial areas
second they could be loaded onto freight
trains this direct access to railways
the cheapest method of land-based
transportation
is in fact a major advantage of the port
of los angeles by far the most common
method of onward transportation from the
port of los angeles is however trucks
they enter through the terminal's gates
hitch up to a waiting container then
drive it to its final destination
whether that be on the other side of the
city or country
so why is it that the maersk essex had
to wait 17 days just to unload its cargo
what part of this system is broken
well in short
all of it
there's no one factor contributing to
the asia to north america supply chain
slowdown but rather the system is just
overloaded
most indicators suggest that
trans-pacific shipping demand is up
about 25 compared to the pre-pandemic
baseline which isn't a massive increase
but it's sort of like congestion on the
highway
traffic is an exponential problem when
one lane is closed on a busy four-lane
highway your journey takes more than 25
percent longer stopping and starting
takes time that adds up and slows the
overall flow down exponentially this is
why ramp meters work they prevent excess
traffic from entering a highway keeping
it at capacity and flowing freely so
even if it takes longer to get on the
highway each person's overall journey
time is less it's the same situation
with ocean shipping it's a system with a
capacity so when it's overloaded by 25
the slowdown is more than 25
once a container is offloaded it's
placed into a sprawling terminal filled
to the brim with an increase in traffic
more trucks than usual are waiting in
line to get through the terminal gates
to pick up their cargo which means
picking up a container takes longer
which means a truck can't get back to
the terminal as quickly which means
there are fewer trucks available to pick
up containers which means more and more
containers stack up in the terminal with
containers leaving the port less quickly
there's less space for new containers
which means it takes longer to unload
ships which means ships are having to
wait longer to get into the port which
means there's less shipping capacity
since journey times are longer and ships
can't get back to asia to pick up a new
load as quickly meanwhile all the
congestion means that terminal operators
are restricting or prohibiting shippers
from sending empty containers back to
asia which means that shippers in asia
are struggling to find containers to use
which means that they're having to buy
new containers which pushes up their
shipping costs
and then all the supply chain chaos
means that shippers are sending goods
earlier which increases demand which
furthers the supply chain disruption
it's not so much a vicious cycle as a
vicious web
chaos compounding chaos
this is what happens when disruption
hits an industry designed to be
extraordinarily standardized a system so
reliant on economies of scale that the
world's largest economy has to rely on
five interface points with the world's
largest manufacturing hub it's a perfect
system a system responsible for many of
the revolutions of the last century but
systems reliant on perfection are those
most vulnerable to disruption
for now though the cogs keep turning the
mars essex is out there somewhere
between california and vietnam shuttling
another load of containers from
continent to continent
probably the most common question i
receive is the most obvious one how do
we make these videos i've finally gotten
around to answering that by making a
video following the process of making
this video from start to finish however
i don't really have a natural place to
put that on youtube so like all the
companion videos we make it's on nebula
that's because nebula is the creator
founded and run streaming service with
no algorithm no ads just the very best
stuff us creators can make whether it be
these quick companion videos long form
big budget nebula originals or our
regular videos early and ad-free of
course we want as many people to watch
this stuff as possible so we partnered
with
stream to make signing up super
affordable it's less than 15 for an
entire year but signing up there means
you also get access to curiosity stream
2 where you can watch their huge catalog
of top-notch non-fiction shows and
documentaries like this episode of
engineering the future about how the
future of cargo ships might actually be
a technology of the past wind power so
two streaming services you'll actually
watch for a year for the price you pay
for a month of other services that
should already be convincing enough but
if not signing up actually helps make
sure that not only wendover but loads of
independent creators are able to keep
creating independently with the stable
income nebula provides so to get this
deal and watch that exclusive behind the
scenes video click the button on screen
or head to curiositystream.comwendover
today